chile acudió a la haya por certeza y la
obtuvo de esta forma categórica resumía
al presidente chileno Gabriel boric la
sentencia leído este jueves por el
tribunal de Justicia del Internacional
de la haya que establece que el cauce
del río silala es un cauce internacional
cuyos recursos deben ser compartidos por
dos países Bolivia y chile se zanja así
una cuestión diplomática de larga Data
que se inició en 2016 cuando chile
acudió a la haya Para demandar a Bolivia
ante las amenazas del entonces
presidente Evo Morales de ese país que
amenazó a Chile con acudir ellos mismos
al tribunal de justicia de la ya para
defender el uso soberano de las aguas
desiderada por parte de Bolivia esta fue
la postura inicial que mantuvo Bolivia
sin embargo en el transcurso del juicio
llegó a admitir que era un cauce
binacional chile además no debe a
Bolivia compensación económica alguna
recalcó borich quien también agradeció
al equipo jurídico que ha defendido a
chile y a las anteriores
administraciones puesto que se trata de
una cuestión de estado transversal y que
no depende del gobierno que esté en este
momento a cargo además el mandatario
emplazó a la vecina Bolivia a trabajar
en aquello que nos une y no lo que nos
separa recordemos que entre ambos países
no existe relaciones diplomáticas desde
1978 también que este es el segundo
revés que sufre Bolivia ante la Corte
Internacional de Justicia en la anterior
fue en una sentencia de 2018 de un
juicio que databa de 2013 en el que
Bolivia pedía a Chile un acceso soberano
al mar